a lyon les son papier leur soutien
donnent de la voix
fermeture des centres de rétention
administrative liberté de circulation et
d'installation régularisation à terme de
tous les sans papiers les revendications
des représentants locaux du collectif
sans papiers sont nombreuses
leur manifestation a débuté par une
minute de silence en hommage à bari
keïta ce travailleur sans papiers morts
le 18 avril dernier lors d'un accident
sur un chantier à pantin en région
parisienne ce que les manifestants
dénoncent l'exploitation selon lui des
sans papiers dans le monde du travail
on voulait parler des départements qui
exploite les immigrés sans papiers
d'accord les uns gastaldon très prudents
les sociétés on travaille mais on gagne
pas de salaire normal voilà mon travail
comme ça me département les fins de mois
et des salaires
- oui à notre
notre travail le travail qu'on fait un
bonne foi
des nageurs qu'il doit qu'il faut
c'est ça qu'on appelle exploitation
depuis plusieurs semaines le collectif
sans papiers de lyon interpellent la
préfecture du rhône sur différents
sujets comme les premiers contacts avec
les services de l'immigration deux mois
dernier n'ont rien donné l'association a
donc décidé de durcir sa mobilisation en
appelant à des rassemblements tous les
vendredis pour faire entendre ses
revendications pour l'impression
pour demander préfecture de nous
répondre déjà pour notre revendication
d'être reçus régulièrement à la
préfecture
pour dénoncer négocier des dossiers de
régularisation des personnes en
situation régulière
de trouver des
des solutions concrètes pour la question
des logements pour les personnes qui
sont abandonnés dans les rues des sdf
les personnes
en difficulté de trouver des logements
et de nous garantir aussi la liberté de
circulation et d'installation déjà
précaire la situation de nombreux
sans-papiers s'est aggravée avec la
crise sanitaire à lyon à paris mais
aussi à toulouse ou encore montpellier
depuis plusieurs semaines des actions se
multiplient pour alerter sur la
situation de ces son papier